well some of it is also just the company
stepping up and just doing it
screw the authority and showing that
it's possible and then the authority
follows so that's why i really
a lot of innovators in the space the the
criticism i have the very sort of
real i don't know harsh criticism i have
towards autonomous vehicle companies in
the space
is
they've gotten culturally
they've it's been it's become acceptable
somehow
to do demos and videos
as opposed to the old school american
way of solving problems
there's there's a culture in silicon
valley where you're talking to vcs
that have lost that kind of
love of um
solving problem they kind of like
envision if the story you told me in
your powerpoint presentation it's true
how many trillions of dollars might i be
able to make there's something lost in
that conversation where you're not
really taking on like
the problem in a real way so these
autonomous vehicle companies realize we
don't need to we just need to make nice
powerpoint presentations and not
actually deliver products that like
everybody looks outside and says holy
this is this is life-changing this
is where i have to give props to waymo
is they put driverless cars on the road
and like
forget powerpoint slide presentations
actual cars on the road then you can
criticize like is that actually going to
work who knows but the thing is they
have cars on the road and that's why i
have to give props to tesla they have
whatever you want to say about risk and
all those kinds of things they have cars
on the road that have some level of
automation and soon they have
trucks on the road as well and that kind
of that component
i think is important part of the policy
conversation because you get you start
getting data of these from these
companies that are willing to take the
big risks as opposed to making slide
decks they're actually putting cars on
the road and like
real lives are at stake they could be
lost and they could bankrupt the company
if they make the wrong decisions and
that that's deeply admirable to me
you